hi this is pressure in this video we're
going to play a game where I'm going to
guess the card that you're staring at
we'll start out with the set of 5 cards
1 2 3 4 5 and I want you to start at the
card number 1 if you want it might be
easier if you place your finger on the
card and fall follow along as we go from
each move the first thing I want you to
do is move from the card number 1 card
to card 3 times and the move has to be
between adjacent cards so you could go
to the number 2 3 and then 4
you could also go to 2 & 3 and then back
to 2 the only move that's not allowed is
you cannot go from 1 to 5 and you can
also not go from 5 to 1 and these rules
are going to be valid for the rest of
the moves we make so go ahead and move
three times once you're done that I want
you to move between cards the number of
times that you voted for President
Barack Obama this will be a number
between 0 & 2
and just to show that I don't I'm fair
to both political parties I want you to
do the same thing for president george w
bush now i want you to make a move that
depends on the day you're watching the
video if the day today is odd like the
15th just move one time and if the day
is even then move two times
now make a move that depends on the card
you're on if you're on an odd card I
want you to move three different times
and if you're on an even card I want you
to move four times and remember you can
move any direction or anything I'm not
going to know where you're at
finally I want you to move left two
times and if you get to the card one
just move back once the other way now
that you're at your card I want you to
really stare at it and it's going to be
the time where I guess which card you're
staring at
so please concentrate so that I can get
a good reading and I'm getting a good
reading and I'm going to say your card
is the number two thanks for watching I
hope you enjoyed this video please
subscribe to my channel you can also
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
on twitter at presh talker and get my
ebooks at Amazon